[Music]
the classic strikes found in iido in
iido we classically practice three
striking techniques that's a showman a
strike done to the front of the head it
either comes from the back hand high to
low the front hand high to low or the
front hand low to high so there the
three ways to PR shman in this the
target is basically the front of Mike's
head right so that's everything from
here down to the front of his head we
also practice Yan which is a strike to
the side of the head that's classically
done from the outside from the back hand
it comes up I step in I'm striking at
the side of Mike's head so it can be
done anywhere in here to be a classic
yokan also sometimes you will see in the
forms that we will go lower with the
yokan and sometimes you also see a gaku
yokan which is a coming from the outside
like this so instead of the technique
coming in this way or from the outside
in it's going to come from the inside
out this is a gaku yokan and in addition
to those two we have one more which is
ski which means thrust so a ski almost
always comes from the back hand and
drives through mik this is the one that
people classically think of as a as a
punch a typical punch um it's important
to understand what these strikes are and
where they come from the strikes found
in iido come from Kum martial arts so
classical Japanese martial arts the
samurai were using weapons all the time
the samurai weren't running out on the
battlefield and boxing or wrestling so
they they weren't using the kind of
techniques we we see now in modern
martial arts right so Jabs or crosses
hooks these kind of these kind of
punches don't don't really happen in
classical martial arts and the reason
they don't happen is because there's a
weapon in the hand now this strike might
look like a really silly strike right if
Mike and I were in a fight and I would
to go ah like this oh and come down on
Mike's head it's kind of silly right um
however when you put a knife in my hand
this is a very normal attack right so
this is exactly what Norman Bates came
after uh the lady in the shower with ins
psycho right so this is a very common
attack you'll see this over and over
again right if you watch um police
footage you'll see people attacking like
this constantly and this is showman this
is done from the front hand coming high
to low that could also be done from the
back hand coming high to low this this
very classic attack um for the Yol woman
we're coming from the outside in so
again empty-handed this looks kind of
foolish but when I have a knife in my
hand you can see this is a very normal
way to attack M or if I was in the for
grip as I come in slashing right in here
I could be slashing at the kateed or
anywhere in here it's a very classic
typical position same's true with the
Kaku Yan it's a very normal strike with
a weapon in your hand now without a
weapon this might be kind of silly a
weird backand or something but with a
weapon you can see this makes perfect
sense and the ski which people normally
think is of a punch this isn't a punch
this is something you thrust into mic so
if I had a knife in my hand you can see
how this is a very normal idea now
there's a lot of recovery you see in a
shorter weapon like say a Tonto I have a
knife right now so I might go in and
come back and you don't see this a lot
the io forms although we do account for
it but imagine if I had a spear driving
a spear in um would be a very classic
thing where I'm trying to push it and
drive it into my so all the classic
weapon strikes is what we see in iido um
for the the yok or the shui going low to
high you could see if I had a sword like
this and we're in close distance I could
use the handle of the sword to strike
Mike so this is our classic showman from
low to high coming up like this so
driving into Mike so it's important when
you're looking at the classic techniques
of IO to understand where they come from
so they don't come from ring fighting or
sport fighting there was never Samurai
running around getting in boxing matches
right they're fighting on the
battlefield with weapons so the classic
strikes you see are going to be weapon
strikes things like yokan showman and
either reverse grip or forgrip and ski
thrusts that are coming in these are the
classic techniques we PR in iido and are
still very useful today classic strikes
of iido